Optimum care Cancer Care the sponsors of
this next segment continue to spread
awareness for breast cancer this month I
spoke with the doctor and the American
Cancer Society to learn to learn more
about how they're making a stride check
it out
so it is Breast Cancer Awareness Month
so we're spreading awareness but also
just reminding women how to take women
and men I should say of how to take care
of themselves during this time
um let's start with you Dr gollar can
you just tell us you know what are the
challenges of breast cancer for women in
particular
absolutely thank you very much it's good
to be here uh this is a very very
important issue for women uh not
counting some types of skin cancer
breast cancers in the U.S the most
common cancer in women no matter your
race or your background it's the most
common cause of death from cancer
amongst Hispanic women and it's the
second most common cause of death
amongst white black Asian Pacific
Islander and Native American women and
what are some of the important physical
signs that these women should be looking
out for
well it's important to keep up with your
breast health and to know what changes
to look for a lump in your breast is the
most common symptom
swelling in and around your breast
collarbone or armpit are also important
if the skin of your breast starts to
feel like an orange peel or gets red uh
that's also important breast warmth and
itching changes in a nipple or discharge
and new pain in one area of the breast
although most breast cancers do not
cause pain some do so if you notice
anything out of the ordinary or any
change uh I think one should not delay
and seen one's health care provided now
Angela let's bring you in you're the
executive director of the American
Cancer Society here in Nevada what
efforts are you guys putting forward
um you know to help prevent breast
cancer the American Cancer Society helps
people with breast cancer in every
community
we work tirelessly to find new drugs and
treatments as well as new ways to use
existing treatments to date the American
Cancer Society has funded over 71
million dollars in breast cancer
research and we play a role in many of
the prevention screening and treatment
advances that save lives from breast
cancer every day
well in one of those programs is reached
to recovery
um can you explain how that supports
these efforts so it is a volunteer
support program and it pairs breast
cancer patients with breast cancer
survivors and it allows them the
opportunity to express feelings talk
about concerns and ask questions of
someone who has been there and made it
through their treatment plan wow that's
such an important program to have
available um you know how can people
help you mention volunteers
I did so we encourage both donations and
volunteering and taking part in our
events coming up on Sunday October 30th
from 7 A.M to 11 A.M we're holding our
making strides Against Breast Cancer
Walk of Las Vegas which happens at Red
Rock Casino it is has always been more
than a walk it's a movement and we make
it easier for anyone anywhere to make an
impact
thank you to Optum care cancer cancer
care for sponsoring this segment call
702-724-8787 or visit optumcancer.com